aber jetzt ist karl lauterbach auf dem
weg zum rednerpult wir haben es also
goldrichtig getroffen der
bundesgesundheitsminister mit seinem
vorhaben in den kommenden jahren
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin wir treten
gerade in das dritte jahr der pandemie
ein und es kann ein ganz entscheidendes
jahr sein für den weiteren verlauf
für uns kann sich entscheiden ob das
kronos zu einem endemischen virus mit
geringer sterblichkeit mit
geringer bedrohung unserer medizinischen
versorgung insgesamt und mit wenig leid
und tod wird oder ob wir diese
gelegenheit verpassen wir müssen alles
daran setzen dass es kein viertes jahr
mit ähnlicher bedrohung für unsere
gesellschaft mehr gibt dafür wird unsere
bundesregierung alle notwendigen
voraussetzungen kressl
noch immer wird die gefahr durch das
kona virus nicht von allen richtig
eingeschätzt oder sogar bewusst
geleugnet dabei sind bereits jetzt mehr
als
115.000 menschen daran gestorben und
sehr viel mehr laden an zum teil
langjährigen ja zum teil lebenslangen
komplikationen der erkrankungen meine
gedanken sind bei den angehörigen meine
gedanken sind bei den nachstehenden die
geliebte menschen verloren haben und bei
denjenigen die nur auf eine heilung
ihrer krankheit warten
obwohl diese zahlen jeden traurig
stimmen müssen sind wir in deutschland
im vergleich zu anderen europäischen
ländern mit ähnlichen altersstruktur
bisher besser durch die pandemie
gekommen diesen erfolg müssen wir bei
der jetzt an fahrt gewinnenden omikron
variante unbedingt fortsetzen und wir
haben die notwendigen mittel dafür
ein wichtiger bestandteil sind die noch
geltenden kontakt beschränkungen nach
wie vor gelten in deutschland zahlreiche
kontakt beschränkungen die zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt die zahl der gesamt kontakte
auf ungefähr die hälfte der kontakte von
vor der pandemie beschenken das ist eine
maßnahme die den bürgerinnen und bürgern
zahlreiche opfer abverlangt hat und
weiter abverlangt aber mit ihr ist es
uns gelungen sowohl die data wie auch
die omikron welle in deutschland zu
verlangsamen sodass wir die hohen
fallzahlen unserer nachbarländer noch
nicht beklagen müssen durch diese
maßnahmen wurden bereits zahlreiche
todesfälle verhindert sowohl mit der
data wie auch der omicron variante ich
danke den bürgerinnen und bürgern die
diese opfer auf sich genommen haben und
hier den weg mit uns gemeinsam gegangen
sind
wir schützen uns selbst und wir schützen
andere dieser schutz ist auch deshalb
von besonderer bedeutung weil wir in
deutschland leider eine hohe zahl von
ungeimpften menschen haben leider auch
in höheren altersgruppen
gerade sie können in den nächsten wochen
durch die anschwellende mikrowelle
besonders gefährdet seien ihre
gefährdung zu leugnen ist auf der
grundlage der vorliegenden studien
fahrlässig
auch höre ich immer wieder dass ihre
gefährdung zwar besteht
für sie aber als gesellschaft kein grund
für schutzmaßnahmen mehr bestehe da sie
ihr recht auf schutz als ungeimpfte
verwirkt hätten eine solche haltung ist
unethisch denn im kampf um das überleben
mit einer krankheit die so heim
glücklich den menschen zerstören kann
ist jeder gleich geimpft oder umgehend
auch das ist ein beitrag zum
zusammenhalt in unserer gesellschaft
was kann außer die strategie sagen im
umgang mit einer so ansteckende variante
wie omikron von der wir wissen dass sie
für ungeimpfte besonders gefährlich ist
zunächst musste appel zumindest die
erste impfung
hinzunehmen die erste impfung zu wählen
an die ungeimpften ergehen die erste
impfung schützt oftmals vor bereits
schwerem verlauf und vertont ich
appelliere daher an ihre vernunft an
alle ungeimpften appelliere an ihre
solidarität schon mit einer einzigen im
um singt ihr risiko tödlich zu erkranken
deutlich viele von uns erbringen große
opfer um sie zu schützen bitte ergreifen
sie die gelegenheit zumindest zur ersten
winter
einen weitreichenden schutz vor
infektionen und schwerer krankheit
bietet allerdings nur die booster
impfung
daher hat die bundesregierung von anfang
an an der offensive und groß angelegte
kampagne für die booster impfung
begonnen für diese kampagne sind
ausreichend impfzentren engagierte ärzte
innen und erste und impfstoffe vorhanden
seitenwagen amtsantritt hat das
bundesgesundheitsministerium
55 millionen dosen booster impfstoff
zusätzlich gekauft für jeden der an der
booster impfung möchte steht der
impfstoff zur verfügung
durch diese kampagne kann es gelingen
aus der wand der mikrowelle einen
steilen hügel zu machen oder zumindest
die höhe der wand zu begrenzen in beiden
fällen rettet das menschenleben und
schützt vor schwerer planender krankheit
das hilft unser gesundheitssystem zu
schützen so dass auch krebspatienten
oder herzpatienten immer gut versorgt
werden auch das muss unser ziel sein
langfristig werden wir die pandemie in
deutschland nur bekennen beenden können
lernen der allergrößte teil der
bevölkerung so geimpft ist das schwerer
verläufe auch mit neuen varianten des
koma virus nicht mehr erwartet werden
können es gibt in der wissenschaftlichen
literatur kaum spezialisten die davon
ausgehen dass die omikron variante die
letzte variante sein wird wir müssen
auch in zukunft mit gefährlichen und
besonders ansteckenden varianten rechnen
bisher gilt dass die impfstoffe von vor
allen bekannten varianten zumindest in
hinsicht dein wirken dass sie vor
schweren verlauf und tod auch bei
älteren menschen und menschen mit
risikofaktoren zuverlässig wirken durch
die anpassung der impfstoffe ist dies
auch in zukunft zu erwarten
daher ist für mich der sicherste und
schnellste weg aus der pandemie heraus
die einführung einer allgemeinen pflicht
in deutschland
den pflicht ist medizinisch geeignet die
frage ist ist sie auch moralisch zu
vertreten aus meiner sicht kann man es
wie folgt bewerten wer sich dem
impfangebot verweigert verletzt sogar
das moralische gebot des kategorischen
imperativs im sinne von immanuel kant
eine solche verweigerung könnte nie die
maxime des handelns für uns alle sein
wenn wir uns alle weigern würden die gut
erforschte und nebenwirkungsarme impfung
zu nutzen um uns selbst oder andere foto
schwerkranker zu schützen würden wir die
pandemie
wahrscheinlich nie beenden können
in der kombination einer wirkungsvollen
impfung für alle erwachsenen und
ebenfalls wirkungsvolle medikamentösen
therapie derjenigen die bei
unvermeidlichen schweren
krankheitsverlaufs trotz impfung
erkranken haben wir eine realistische
maßvolle möglichkeit die pandemie in der
kombination von impfungen und
medikamentöser behandlung zu beenden
diese möglichkeit sollten wir dringend
ergreifen
wir beenden damit nicht nur
die opfer die die vielen
pflichtbewussten erbringen wir würden
ändern damit auch die opfer die unsere
kinder erbringen wir beenden damit
vermeidbares leid wir beenden damit
einen belagerungszustand unserer
gesellschaft durch ein virus wir haben
die mittel in der hand wie sollten sie
ergreifen wir sollten eine allgemeine
impfpflicht
einführen gründlich aber in der zeit
dass wir ein viertes jahr der pandemie
nicht erneut so eröffnen müssen die wir
jetzt gezwungen sind es zu eröffnen wir
können dies gemeinsam als gesellschaft
erreichen und dafür stehen wir gemeinsam
ein
soweit also bundesgesundheitsminister
karl lauterbach gehört mittlerweile zu
den beliebtesten politikern in der
republik hat sich hier noch einmal für
die herbeiführung einer allgemeinen
impfpflicht
ausgesprochen karl lauterbach ist ein
sogenannter quereinsteiger der erst spät
den weg in die politik fand er studierte
medizin epidemiologie und
gesundheitsmanagement in deutschland war
universitätsprofessoren köln und ist
seit 2005 mitglied im bundestag der
erste redner in dieser debatte der
gesundheitspolitische sprecher der cdu
csu tino sorge
lauterbach ich glaube wir sind uns
größtenteils in diesem hohen hause hier
einig dass die bekämpfung der pandemie
eine der wichtigsten aufgaben nicht nur
der letzte sondern auch dieser
legislatur werden wird umso überraschter
das sage ich ihnen ganz offen war ich
dass sie hier kein einziges wort darüber
verloren haben in welcher funktion sie
jetzt gerade gesprochen haben sie haben
von der wichtigkeit gegen die omikron
variante zu kämpfen gesprochen sie haben
davon gesprochen dass impfen die
impfpflicht eine möglichkeit wäre die
omikron wand zu brechen sie haben das
nicht gesagt als minister also wenn sie
das als minister so sehen dann erwarte
ich von ihnen auch ein gesetzesvorschlag
und gehen sind sie bisher immer
unschuldige tiere aber das ist ja
insofern das interessante an der ganzen
konstellation dass sie in den letzten
tagen erheblich für konfusion gesorgt
haben sie habe immer gesagt in den
letzten wochen sie seien für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht das haben sich
hier gerade wieder getan sie habe aber
nicht gesagt ist das jetzt die meinung
des ministers ist dass die meinung des
einfachen abgeordneten karl lauterbach
ist dass die meinung zu wies gestern der
bundeskanzler olaf scholz immer hier
gemacht hat der privatperson dass scholz
oder privatpersonen karl lauterbach das
haben sie hier auch wieder nicht klar
und deutlich gemacht und ich darf sie
noch hand ihrer ausführung noch am 17
dezember in ein bussi gesagt haben die
heute auch die grundwerte alles
übertreffen was wir in der gesamten kann
denn je bisher gesehen haben olaf scholz
hat im dezember noch gesagt es dürfe bei
der pandemie bekämpfung keine roten
linien geben und deshalb finde ich sehr
gut dass sie an das parlament verweisen
dass sie sagen wir parlamentarier müssen
uns damit beschäftigen sie haben dem
parlament im ausschuss auf ihre
parlamentarische staatssekretärin auch
sämtliche unterstützung angeboten dass
das was sie hier tun wenn sie das
parlament zu schätzen warum beantworten
sie dann die fragen nicht unsere fragen
auch der opposition lieber herr kollege
lauterer und wir haben ihn
bereits vor weihnachten einen
umfangreichen fragenkatalog zur
verfügung gestellt indem wir darauf
hingewiesen haben welche fragen
beantwortet werden müssen wir reden
nicht über politische fragen geräten
über ethische fragen wir reden über
fachliche fragen die reden ganz normal
über eine datengrundlage die notwendig
ist auch aus sicht des ministeriums
damit dieses parlament sich hier eine
meinung bilden kann und ich will ihn
auch noch mal vielleicht haben sie die
fragen gar nicht gelesen ganz konkret
sagen worum es dabei geht wir haben sie
gefragt welches primäre ziel soll mit
einer impfpflicht überhaupt verfolgt
werden von ihnen bis heute keine antwort
wir haben sie gefragt welche rolle
spielen omikron und neue medikamente die
pax gebiet von ihnen bis heute keine
antwort wir haben sie gefragt wie wollen
sie überhaupt die fachexperten und die
expertise der bundesländer einbinden von
ihnen bis heute sie können sich
vorstellen keine antwort und das setzt
sich seit tagen sofort lieber herr
kollege lauter war
und ich möchte auch noch auf dieses
dröhnende schweigen in anderen bereichen
eingehen sie haben angesprochen ziel 30
millionen impfungen bis ende januar das
hat olaf scholz als boden kanzler auch
vollmundig versprochen bis ende januar
soll es gelingen weitere 30 millionen
impfungen zu verabreichen auch hier ist
momentan völlig offen wie wollen sie
dieses ziel erreichen ich darf nur
darauf hinweisen die impfkampagne ist
zwei tagen weit entfernt von dieser 1
millionen impfungen die wir pro tag
bräuchten wir lieben gerade einmal bei
der hälfte dieser notwendigen impfungen
und das liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ist ein punkt der grenzt schon fast an
arbeitsverweigerung
und da können sie auch all jene jesu
laut schreiben wie sie möchten der
nächste punkt sage ich ihnen auch vor
weihnachten haben sie das ziel
ausgerufen ihr bundeskanzler impfquote
bis ende januar 80 prozent erreichen und
was ist passiert auch hier müssten wir
täglich 142000 gast und zu machen wir
sind nicht an einem der letzten tage
auch nur ansatzweise in diese
größenordnung bekommen in den letzten
tagen waren es nicht einmal die hälfte
und deshalb eine ganz konkrete fragen an
den herrn ministers konnte er gestern im
ausschuss stellen sie war der leider
nicht da wie und was tun sie konkret um
diese hochgesteckten ziele zu erreichen
das wäre sehr interessant wenn sie uns
das mal erklären würden
und wir haben ja nun keine eine
angst seit einer kanzlerin erlebt die
uns in diesem land viel gutes gebracht
hat und die ist ja immer kritisiert
wurden dafür dass man gesagt hat angela
merkel werde dafür die politik der
ruhigen hand bekannt gewesen aber herr
kollege lauterbach das kann ich ihm und
dem bundeskanzler nicht ersparen bei ihm
kann man ja nicht mal davon reden dass
sie mit der politik der ruhigen hand
regieren würden bei ihnen ist es eher
die politik der eingeschlafenen füße
liebe kolleginnen und
da kommen laufend neue versprechungen
und dann lange nichts und deshalb die
bitte an sie als bundesregierung auch an
sie herr kollege lauterbach sie
verweisen immer auf diese fachexperte
die wissenschaftliche expertise das sind
wir uns einer meinung die ganz ganz
wichtig ist auch für die beurteilung und
für die bekämpfung der pandemie
übernehmen sie als regierung führen in
diesem land das wird von ihnen erwartet
verhalten sie sich nicht die eine
nichtregierungsorganisation
das können wir uns in deutschland nicht
erlaubt und insofern regierung bedeutet
regieren fangen sie endlich damit an
vielen dank
[Applaus]
tino sorge war dass für die cdu/csu er
erwarte einen gesetzesvorschlag des
ministers und auch des bundeskanzlers
das war ja auch schon thema gestern bei
der befragung von olaf scholz warum sind
der kanzler und der gesundheitsminister
für eine gesetzliche pflicht und warum
legen sie da nicht ein gesetz vor diese
frage stellt die opposition auch heute
die nächste rednerin jetzt hier kirsten
kappert konter für die bundes gründen
die ganze welt viele menschen haben den
eindruck in einem zug zu sitzen wir
durch einen langen tunnel fährt statt
auf der anderen seite des berges ins
licht zu kommen wird es oder scheint es
so als würde es immer dunkler und klar
ist wir müssen diesen zug bremsen weil
dann wird es auch wieder heller liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und das ist nicht einfach
während der zug fährt gleichzeitig die
schienen zu bauen um ihn heraus zu
leiten und nicht nur unser
gesundheitsminister sondern die ganze
koalition sieht dies als unsere
vordringlichste aufgabe an und lieber
kollege tino sorge ich habe mich schon
sehr gewundert über ihren der beitrag
keine verantwortungsübernahme für die
letzten jahre ich möchte sagen
jahrzehnte und kein einziger vorschlag
kein einziger konstruktiver vorschlag
was sie denn nun anders machen würden
dass wir schon sehr irritieren denn
eigentlich denn eigentlich erlebe ich
sie so erlebe ich auch ihre fraktion so
erlebe ich auch weite teile der
opposition zu da so dass sie konstruktiv
daran mit mir tun wollen diese pandemie
zu überwinden und das ist auch dringend
notwendig dass wir das alle gemeinsam
tonträger kolleginnen und kollegen
und bezüglich machen in der
konstruktivität haben wir leider ein
sehr schlechtes beispiel auf die im
deutschen bundestag die afg streut
falsche informationen diskreditiert
gesundheitsexpertin entführt angst in
der pandemie um unsere demokratie
anzugreifen und das gefährdet die
gesundheit von menschen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wettkampf werden diese pandemie und der
einsatz für demokratie gehen hand in
hand und die müssen hand in hand gehen
und menschlichkeit
gegenseitige anteilnahme das ist
grundlegend um diese pandemie zu
überwinden und sind für unsere seelen
elementar und vielen menschen fehlt
gerade jetzt der ansprechpartner die
ansprechpartnerin einsamkeit ist in
unserer gesellschaft ein zunehmendes
problem das war vor bewohner so und das
wird durch corona jetzt verschlimmert
überhaupt unsere seelische gesundheit
steht sehr unter druck einerseits sehen
wir wie wir als menschen ziemlich
resilient sind unter sehr schwierigen
bedingungen auch als gesellschaft
resilienz sind im
angesichts dieser existenziellen
bedrohungen aber dir wissen eben auch
dass wenn die äußeren drucksituationen
nachlassen und die werden hoffentlich
nachlassen das sich dann seelische
wunden vor allem zeigen also im verlauf
erst zunehmend zeigen und das bedeutet
wir werden mehr aufmerksamkeit der
seelischen gesundheit widmen müssen wir
brauchen bessere und mehr zugänge zu
psychotherapie die wartezeiten sind
jetzt schon zu lang und da ist es gut
dass diese koalition erstmals in einem
koalitionsvertrag auf bundesebene dem
thema seelische gesundheit eine zentrale
rolle bei nicht
medizin ethische fragen stehen im fokus
der öffentlichkeit im flüchtiger schritt
assistenz all diese debatten werden wir
hier im parlament führen und sorgfältig
und ernsthaft führen und die pandemie
zeigt uns gesundheit entsteht im alltag
unter welchen bedingungen wir leben das
hat einen relevanten einfluss auf unsere
gesundheit und darum heißt es ja auch im
koalitionsvertrag dass der leitgedanke
von vorsorge und prävention im zentrum
stehen muss und dieser satz der sagt so
viel ja der bedeutet gesundes essen
soziale gerechtigkeit
geschlechtergerechte
gesundheitsversorgung gute geburtshilfe
und auch dass klimaschutz immer
gesundheitsschutz ist und auch in der
drogenpolitik liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen steht die prävention künftig
endlich an erster stelle viele menschen
haben sich zum teil seit jahrzehnten
dafür eingesetzt die ampel macht es
jetzt möglich die kontrollierte freigabe
von cannabis kommt
liebe kollegin collien das in große
vorhaben das kann niemand alleine nicht
wir im parlament alleine nicht als
koalition sondern nur gemeinsam mit
vielen menschen draußen die tagtäglich
für unsere gesundheit sorgen versetzen
wir berge stoppen wir den rasenden zug
lenken ihnen gute bahn gehen wir diese
großen kollegen projekt in der
gesundheitspolitik endlich an ich danke
ihnen
kirsten kaputt bunter war das hier für
die bündnisgrünen der bundestag
debattiert über den bereich
gesundheitspolitik und martin sichert
der gesundheitspolitische sprecher der
fdp-fraktion hat jetzt ein wortbeitrag
von der tribüne
als freiheitlicher mensch möchte ich
zuerst allen danken die unter zum teil
großen persönlichen entbehrungen
solidarisch sind die vergangenen wochen
haben bewiesen je mehr geimpft und je
mehr gemustert sind umso
diskriminierende maßnahmen verhängen die
regierungen gegen jene die nicht bereit
sind sich alle drei oder sechs monate
schützen zu lassen der nötigung der
regierung zu widerstehen ist ein großer
akt der solidarität in der ist ein
beitrag zur freiheit von millionen
menschen vielen dank dafür
die gesundheitspolitik muss endlich
wieder die gesundheit der menschen im
fokus haben anstatt als feigenblatt für
willkürliche spaltung und
diskriminierung zu denen mit 2g plus
setzen sie den bundestag mit einer
kneipe gleich und sagen zugleich dass er
kein arbeitsplatz ist denn am
arbeitsplatz gilt steige sie wollen
immer angeblich demokratischen
fraktionen seien setzten aber den
bundestag mit einer kneipe gleich das
ist absolut
bremen bremen hat mit 85 prozent die
höchste quote aller bundesländer während
sachsen mit 61 prozent die niedrigste
hat bremen hat die mit abstand höchste
instanz aller bundesländer und sachsen
die niedrigste wo 85
85 prozent geimpft sind ist die inzidenz
mehr als fünfmal so hoch wie da wo nur
61 prozent geimpft sind ja ich weiß
jetzt kommt wieder irgendwann
schauberger daher und sagt aber die
impfung schützt vor schwerem verlauf
auch das stimmt nicht in bremen ist die
hospitalisierung incidents doppelt so
hoch wie in allen anderen bundesländern
und mehr als dreimal so hoch wie in
sachsen
gemäß dem letzten wochen bericht des lka
waren bei den toten bei den
hospitalisierten
und den erkrankten mit omikron
überproportional viele gemustert oder
geimpft während knapp 30 prozent der
bevölkerung nicht vollständig geimpft
sind waren nur 22 prozent der omicron
erkrankten nicht vollständig geimpft
wenn wir uns diese zahlen zeigen die
eigene impfung die geimpften und
geposteten nicht schützt wieso sollten
sie dann durch eine impfung der
ungeübten geschützt sein
dazu kommen die massiven nebenwirkungen
das paul ehrlich institut meldet in elf
monaten wir mal mehr tote nach impfung
bei corona als in den letzten 20 jahren
bei allen anderen impfungen zusammen
alle 5000 impfungen wird ein fall
schwerer nebenwirkungen wie eine
herzmuskelentzündung gemeldet und keiner
weiß und wie viel höher die dunkelziffer
ist oder welche langzeitfolgen die
impfung verursacht bei der zahl der
belegten intensivbetten liegen wir
übrigens seit wochen deutlich unter dem
durchschnitt der letzten zwei jahre wie
viele auf den intensivstationen games
sind wissen wir übrigens auch immer noch
nicht nach einem jahr im funk seit mitte
dezember wird zwar von der divi erfasst
aber aus den zahlen macht man ein
staatsgeheimnis ein skandal denn wer
massive maßnahmen verhängt der muss den
bürgern auch die tatsächlichen daten
präsentieren
nicht nur rechtlich und moralisch
sondern auch gesundheitspolitisch gibt
es keine grundlage menschen aufgrund
ihres impfstatus zu diskriminieren die
korona maßnahmen sind auch gift für die
gesundheit experten sagen uns dass
deutlich mehr menschen an krebs sterben
werden weil viel weniger zur vorsorge
gehen jedes jahr sterben ca
240.000 menschen in deutschland an krebs
wenn nur zehn prozent sterben sind das
24.000 menschen denen ein qualvoller
leidensweg bis zum tod bevorsteht
24.000 sind übrigens weit mehr menschen
als bisher als corona tote in allen
altersgruppen bis 69 jahren gestorben
sind
am schlimmsten traf die politik der
vergangenen zwei jahre die jugend die
zahl der jugendlichen die wegen
suizidversuchen letztes jahr auf den
intensivstationen gelandet sind ist
drastisch angestiegen wegen abstand und
maske kann das immunsystem der kinder
nicht ausreichend trainieren weswegen
kinder deutlich anfälliger für andere
krankheiten sind wir werden
jahrzehntelang die folgen der
psychischen und gesundheitlichen
belastung der kinder ausbaden müssen es
ist allerhöchste zeit endlich alle
maßnahmen gegen kinder und jugendliche
umgehend aufzuheben
es gibt es gibt einen weg aus coruna
seit einem jahr ist ein urintest
zugelassenen der ab dem ersten tag der
infektion die schwere des verlaufs
prognostizieren kann zusammen mit
monoklonalen antikörper hätte man viele
schwere verläufe verhindern können
leider passte das aber nicht in das
konzept den menschen die impfung
anzudrehen spätestens mit den seit
november zugelassenen wirksamen
medikamenten gegen schwere verläufe
entfällt die grundlage für eine
impfpflicht
lassen sie uns
lassen sie uns tests und medikamente
jeden der sich infiziert anbieten so
können wir auch allen ängstlichen einen
weg aus corona zeigen spanien und
schweden sind zur alten normalität
zurückgekehrt es wird zeit dass wir in
deutschland das auch tun
[Applaus]
als eine der ersten maßnahmen müssen wir
die impfpflicht für medizinisches
personal aufheben denn sie verschärft
den pflegemangel dazu kommt in der
pflege verbringt jede vierte pflegekraft
mehr als die hälfte ihrer arbeitszeit
mit bürokratie hätte die pflegekraft das
gewollt dann hätte sie wohl eine
ausbildung zum bürokaufmann gemacht bei
der pflege muss wieder die fürsorge für
die betreuten personen in den
mittelpunkt gerückt werden anstelle dem
ausfüllen von formularen und wir können
uns auch nicht mit einem bonus für
pflegekräfte aus der verantwortung
stehlen es braucht langfristig eine
anständige bezahlung um diesen beruf
attraktiv zu machen
und auch wenn hier die meisten privat
versichert sind möchte ich ihnen
nahelegen beschäftigen sich auch mit den
kassenpatienten damit das größte problem
im gesundheitssystem ist dass
kassenpatienten oft monatelang auf
termine warten müssen das muss dringend
geändert werden denn eine zeitnahe
untersuchung oder behandlung ist auch
eine frage von leben und tod sie sehen
es gibt auch abseits von corona viel zu
tun beenden wir nach zwei jahren endlich
den fokus auf nur eine krankheit vielen
dank
für die fdp-fraktion gegnerin hier in
der debatte ist die
gesundheitspolitische sprecherin der fdp
bundestagsfraktion
christine aschenberg-dugnus
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen bevor ich mich
den zielen unserer fortschritts
koalition im bereich gesundheit widmen
möchte ich gerne auf die aktuelle corona
lage eingehen die infektionszahlen
steigen erheblich an und durch die hoch
ansteckende omikron variante werden die
zahlen voraussichtlich auch in den
nächsten wochen noch erheblich weiter
nach oben gehen wir verfolgen als
koalition dieses infektionsgeschehen
sehr genau und nehmen die lage auch sehr
ernst und gerade deshalb werde ich es
nicht würde allen immer wieder zuzurufen
die einzige maßnahme das wirksamste
mittel gegen korona und gerade gegen
omikron ist impfen und bus dann meine
damen und herren
und deshalb im und poster deutschland
gerade was das zeug hält das erste
etappenziel 30 millionen user impfung
bis ende des jahres ist erreicht worden
wir sind poster europa weltmeister meine
damen und herren und weitere impfungen
werden demnächst folgen und damit muss
ich sagen ausreichend impfstoff vielen
dank karl lauterbach ist vorhanden und
das ist ja die voraussetzung auch dafür
und
dieser stelle möchte ich auch mich bei
allen beteiligten bedanken die damit
geholfen haben und damit meine ich alle
impfenden die impfenden in den praxen in
den impfzentren in den betrieben in den
pflegeeinrichtungen und in den mobilen
teams herzlichen dank für ihren einsatz
für unser land meine damen und herren
unsere maßnahmen der fortschritts
regierungen haben das übrigens auch
möglich gemacht erstens wir haben den
kreis der impf berechtigten erweitert
denn vor allem junge menschen haben
keinen hausarzt und deswegen gehen sie
zum impfen auch lieber in die apotheke
oder zum zahnarzt zweitens die logistik
in den händen der bundeswehr
funktioniert das war eine gute maßnahme
der regierung
brittens der expertenrat berät jetzt die
bundesregierung bei ihren entscheidungen
entscheidungen und das schafft auch das
notwendige vertrauen in der bevölkerung
auch das war eine notwendige maßnahme
und viertens das ganze wieder offen und
transparent im parlament diskutiert
meine damen und herren sowie heute abend
zum beispiel auch die schützen aber
ausnahmeverordnung
und dafür haben wir lange gekämpft dass
das passiert und wir haben es umgesetzt
die pandemie bekämpfung unserer
bundesregierung ist planvoll
unverhältnismäßig und meine damen und
herren das ganze ohne lockdown und vor
allem ohne
schulschließungen denn unsere kinder
dürfen nicht wieder die verlierer dieser
pandemie sein wie der spiegel gestern
berichtet hat ist die nachfrage nach
therapieplätzen in der kinder und
jugendpsychiatrie
extrem nach oben gegangen und leider
auch die suizidversuche bei jugendlichen
und kindern wer nach einem lockdown
verlangt darf diese tatsache nicht außer
acht lassen meine damen
nun zu den bereits angekündigten
gesundheitspolitischen zielen dieser
unserer regierung des fortschritts wir
werden mit einer
digitalisierungsstrategie die
modernisierung des gesundheitswesens
vorantreiben denn die panini hat uns
doch sehr deutlich vor augen geführt wie
wichtig es ist schnell und zuverlässig
daten zu erhalten und vor allen dingen
die gesundheits akteure miteinander zu
vernetzen wer das land modernisieren
möchte und das wollen wir muss das
gesundheitswesen digitalisieren und das
werden wir jetzt angehen meine damen und
herren als weiteren wichtigen punkt wir
wollen auch die überflüssige bürokratie
abschaffen ganz konsequent denn die zeit
des papier ausfüllen es ist vorbei dass
diese zeit ist besser bei den
patientinnen und patienten investiert
ich könnte noch viele weitere punkte
nennen aber einen letzten punkt
gestatten sie mir noch die mir sehr am
herzen liegt und das ist die pflege
pflegekräfte und vor allen dingen
pflegende angehörige leisten großartiges
und wachsen täglich über sich hinaus sie
verdienen unsere anerkennung und unsere
unterstützung deswegen werden wir eine
ausbildungsoffensive für die pflege
staaten mit bundesweiten
qualitätsstandards und einer förderung
der pflegewissenschaften und der
pflegeforschung und meine damen und
herren 1 könnte ihnen versichern der
pflege bonus kommt vielen dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat die kollegin kathrin vogler
für die fraktion die linke
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
kolleginnen und kollegen ja herr
lauterbach als gesundheitsminister in
der schwersten und längsten
gesundheitskrise unseres landes die sie
mit einer in teilen in weiten teilen
privatisierten und kaputt gesparten
infrastruktur bewältigen müssen stehen
sie vor riesigen aufgaben
sie wurden ja von einer großen
öffentlichen erwartungshaltung
tragen und daran an diesen erwartungen
für ein besseres krisenmanagement
werden nicht nur wir sie messen ich
glaube ich spreche für alle
demokratischen fraktionen dieses hauses
wenn ich ihnen wirklich von herzen
wünsche dass sie dabei erfolgreich sind
denn es geht um viel um sehr viel um
leben und gesundheit um sicherheit
freiheit und um die lebenschancen von
millionen menschen in diesem land
die linke steht immer dafür ein dass
alle menschen bestmöglichen zugang zu
schutz und guter medizinischer
versorgung bekommen und deswegen hat ja
auch unsere berliner
gesundheitssenatorin katja kipping als
allererstes im amt erst mal 1,4
millionen ffp zwei masken beschafft die
kostenlos an finanziell benachteiligte
menschen an arme und obdachlose verteilt
werden und das ist gut so und im
gegensatz zu cdu csu kann man sich
übrigens bei uns darauf verlassen dass
nicht ein einziger abgeordneter aus
unserer partei da auch nur 10 cent
verdient so meine damen und herren so
geht soziale pandemie bekämpfen so muss
man das machen
von corona aber auch von vielen anderen
krankheiten sind nämlich nicht alle
gleich betroffen wie das immer behauptet
wird und es ist auch nicht ein virus der
unser land spaltet sondern eine politik
die seit vielen jahren die reichen
schont und die armut verschärft
und um genau das auf den fokus zu lenken
haben wir professor dr der hat als
bundespräsidenten nominiert ein
mediziner der seine überzeugungen seit
vielen jahren für die überwindung von
armut und das menschenrecht auf
gesundheit für alle kämpft jemanden der
obdachlose geflüchtete und menschen ohne
krankenversicherung behandelt ohne
danach zu fragen wer ist eigentlich der
kostenträger und war fast so für einen
aufenthaltsstatus und meine damen und
herren in einem sozialstaat sollte das
eine selbstverständlichkeit sein wer
krank ist bekommt hilfe punkt
leider
leider ist in diesem jahr die wertigkeit
aber eine andere und viele menschen
leiden unter darunter und das sollte
übrigens auch klar sein dass diese hilfe
dass alle diejenigen die diese hilfe
leisten dafür anständig bezahlt um
anständig behandelt werden dass jetzt
die bundesregierung mit großem bohei
eine corona prämie für pflegekräfte
ankündigt und dann aber erstmal
langwierig herausfinden möchte wer denn
überhaupt genug belastet war um die auch
verdient zu haben
nachdem sie es geschafft haben in nur
vier tagen eine einrichtung bezogene
impfpflicht durch dieses parlament zu
bringen das finde ich wirklich unfassbar
und völlig unangemessen
der
koalitionsvertrag der ampel verspricht
bessere medizinische versorgung mehr
prävention mehr inklusion und bessere
arbeitsbedingungen in der pflege das ist
alles überfällig und dabei werden wir
sie selbstverständlich unterstützen aber
man muss schon noch mal die frage
stellen wie wollen sie das eigentlich
finanzieren wenn sie nicht das
zweiklassensystem aus privat und
gesetzlich versicherten aufbrechen
wollen und wenn sie auch
darauf verzichten zumindest über höhere
steuern die exorbitanten krisengewinner
der konzerne abzuschöpfen also
wenn ich alle in eine kasse einzahlen
und damit die die lasten denn
gesundheitsversorgung gerechter verteilt
werden dann werden wir doch keine nicht
mehr geld zur verfügung haben und vor
allem wenn dann müssen die versicherten
dass durch höhere beiträge bezahlen und
steigende beiträge bei den krankenkassen
die belasten vor allem diejenigen die
sowieso wenig geld haben seit neujahr
zeit etwa jeder vierte gesetzlich
versicherte höhere beiträge und das ist
zusätzlich zur höheren stromrechnung zur
steigenden mieten und zu den gestiegenen
heizkosten und den lebensmittelpreisen
und das ist wirklich inakzeptabel meine
damen und herren
kommt zum schluss
meiner auffassung ist dass unser
gesundheitswesen mit kleinen reförmchen
nicht zu retten ist dass wir einen
systemwechsel brauchen die gesundheit
und pflege endlich den kapitalinteressen
entzieht und sie als öffentliches gute
larssons vorsorge organisiert und darf
jetzt steht die linke
katja die gesundheitspolitische
sprecherin der linksfraktion der
bundestag debattiert den zweiten tag die
verschiedenen ministerien und die
politik der bundesregierung heute hier
in diesen minuten geht es um das
gesundheitsressort und die nächste
rednerin die sehen wir schon im bild
dagmar schmidt sie ist eine der
stellvertretenden fraktionsvorsitzenden
der spd
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
damen und herren wir alle sind der
pandemie müde und trotzdem ist sie zu
recht das wichtigste thema und man muss
heute in dieser debatte etwas dazu sagen
und auch wenn es richtig ist dass es
menschen in unterschiedlichen
lebenslagen und situationen
unterschiedlich hart trifft 1 kann man
glaube ich festhalten kinder jugendliche
und junge erwachsene trifft es am
härtesten langer zeit war der unterricht
nur digital da mal im wechsel modell
oftmals war unzuverlässig die quarantäne
hat vor allem diejenigen familien in die
verzweiflung getrieben wo mehrere kinder
in der schule immer wieder betroffen
waren und es immer noch sind unzählige
schul und berufsabschlüsse konnten nicht
gefeiert werden die berufsorientierung
und lebensplanung ist schwer geworden
viele kinder jugendliche aber auch
erwachsene hat es aus der bahn geworfen
und auf teile der wirtschaft sind
besonders hart betroffen gastronomie
kultur tourismus besonders trifft es die
solo selbstständigen und wir erleben
gerade die höchsten infektionszahlen
dieser pandemie und sie ist noch nicht
vorbei auch wenn sich das alles so sehr
wünschen und deswegen gilt es einen
paradigmenwechsel einzuleiten und das
hat auch mit der neuen regierung schon
begonnen denn nicht wie man es sich
wünscht dass es mit der pandemie weiter
geht darf der maßstab des politischen
handelns sein sondern sich
vorausschauend auf alles vorzubereiten
wir wollen endlich vor die lage kommen
dazu hat die bundesregierung zuerst
einen krisenstab im kanzleramt
eingerichtet und das 30 millionen
impfungen vergangenen dezember möglich
wurden ist eben das verdienst von
generalmajor proyer und seinem stab aber
auch von all denjenigen die in den
hausarztpraxen in den impfzentren und
mit viel fantasie und initiative in
kirchen in moscheen und an vielen
anderen orten zum impfen einladen und
damit erfolgreich sind ihnen allen ein
ganz großes dankeschön und macht weiter
so
zum zweiten bekommt mit dem expertenrat
will sich wissenschaftliche expertise
endlich eine institutionalisierte rolle
und wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse
werden und immer wieder angepasst an die
aktuellen studien zur grundlage des
politischen handelns sich gut
vorzubereiten dazu gehört aber auch dass
der bund die finanzierung der
impfzentren bis zum jahresende zugesagt
hat auch die testzentren können ihre
arbeit wie gewohnt fortsetzen und auch
die krankenhäuser erhalten für die
verschiebung planbare operationen
unterstützung vom bund die
gesundheitsinfrastruktur wird so für den
weiteren verlauf der pandemie gesichert
und gestärkt und das ist auch gut so und
zu all den vorausschauenden maßnahmen
und instrumenten und initiativen mit
denen wir vor die lage und aus der
pandemie kommen wollen gehört auch die
debatte um die impfpflicht wir werden
das in der nächsten sitzungswoche
ausführlich beraten aber so viel sei
schon einmal gesagt wenn wir das ziel
teilen dass dieses auf und ab auf und zu
und wieder eine neue welle wenn wir
wollen dass das endet und wenn wir nicht
den weg gehen wollen es darauf ankommen
zu lassen mit dem risiko dass menschen
sterben und schwer erkranken dann
sollten wir demokratinnen und demokraten
die nächsten wochen dazu nutzen
gemeinsam über die impfpflicht und alle
anderen instrumente zur bekämpfung der
pandemie sachlich und ergebnisorientiert
zu diskutieren ich lade sie alle dazu
herzlich ein
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen man lernt
in dieser pandemie nicht nur vielen
bezug auf den charakter des einen oder
der anderen im positiven wie im
negativen es gibt auch einige lehren und
aufgaben aus der pandemie die nicht alle
neu aber wieder zurecht auf der
tagesordnung sind dazu haben wir einiges
im koalitionsvertrag aufgeschrieben
erstens mehr respekt vor der arbeit im
gesundheitssystem wir werden die
pflegeberufe aufwerten mit besseren
löhnen besseren arbeitsbedingungen und
mehr dazu nachher noch von meiner
kollegin heike behrens zweitens jahre
lang und das gilt nicht nur für den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst hat
gegenüber den kommunen die aussage
gegolten baut stellen ab koste es was es
wolle denn es kostet zu viel und was es
kostet das sehen wir jetzt das ergebnis
sind überlastete verwaltungen die ihre
aufgaben erst recht in einer solchen
ausnahmesituation nicht mehr
bürgerfreundlich ausführen können
deswegen werden wir unter anderem den
pakt für den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst fortsetzen bei bedarf
mit weiteren mitteln ausstatten und das
sage ich hier auch die länder in dieser
frage nicht aus der verantwortung
drittens digitalisierung ist ein
riesenthema für die ampel faxe
ausgedruckte formulare die anderswo
wieder händisch eingegeben werden müssen
briefe statt e-mails behörden die daten
nicht miteinander austauschen können
verzögerungen mangelnde übersicht und
mangelnder informationsfluss das ist
nicht mehr hinnehmbar weder im
gesundheitswesen noch in den anderen
bereichen unseres sozialstaats und
unserer verwaltung das gehen wir mit
nachdruck an
und wird uns einfacher zugang und
einfache unterstützung und hilfe darf
nicht vom wohnort abhängen deswegen
führen wir mit der gemeindeschwester ein
neues berufsbild ein und helfen kommunen
beim aufbau medizinischer
versorgungszentren das und vieles andere
haben wir alles vor und ich freue mich
drauf gehen dann
aber nochmal gesagt was die koalition
plant das ist natürlich alles viel geld
und angesichts der dramatischen
finanzlage gerade in den gesetzlichen
krankenversicherung geht die koalition
von einer steigenden steuern
finanzierung aus hier sehen wir schon
sehr müller er ist für diesen bereich
der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion und er
bekommt jetzt hier das wort im plenum
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren geschätzter
kollege lauterbach hier wurde
gesundheitsminister wir als unions
fraktion stehen an ihrer seite wenn es
um das thema bekämpfung der pandemie
geht wir werden bei allen maßnahmen die
dafür notwendig sind diese pandemie in
den griff zu kriegen auch an der seite
der ampel koalition stehen dafür
wünschen wir ihnen alles gute gottes
segen und viel erfolg dass wir diese
nationale katastrophe endlich hinter uns
bringen
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
aber nun ist die ampel koalition am zug
und die ampel hat schon nach einem monat
auf rot geschaltet und was heißt rot rot
heißt olaf scholz rot heißt versprochen
gebrochen versprochen nummer eins im
dezember letzten jahres dass bis
weihnachten
30 millionen booster impfungen in die
oberarme gegeben werden es waren 25
millionen versprochen nummer zwei am 7
januar dieses jahres das bis ende januar
weitere 30 millionen booster impfungen
in die oberarme kommen das wird nicht
erreichbar sein versprochen gebrochen
herr scholz und das nächste versprechen
das kann der bundeskanzler olaf scholz
nicht einhalten das ist die ganze
thematik der allgemeinen impfpflicht
hier ist ein gesetzentwurf vorgeschlagen
worden bis ende februar anfang märz herr
lauterbach sie haben heute erklärt dass
sie selbst keinen mehr einbringt diese
regierung ist keine fortschritts
koalition diese regierung ist eine ampel
dieser ampel steht auf rot und rot heißt
olaf scholz meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren wie kommen wir aus dieser
pandemie heraus sie sagen sie vertrauen
auf wissenschaftlichen rat
warum haben sie denn nicht auf den
expertenrat gehört der expertenrat hat
nicht zweig plus gefordert diese
regierung setzt zweig plus um und
fordert dies ohne dass der expertenrat
getan hat die experten haben vor
weihnachten herr lauterbach bereits
darauf hingewiesen dass wir im
schlimmsten falle
750.000 neuinfektionen im alltag haben
werden bayern gekümmert bereits vor
weihnachten hat unsere fraktion
gefordert pcr tests als burge verfahren
oder im pool verfahren auszuweiten auf
gemeinschaftseinrichtungen die
altenpflegeheime kitas und schulen
anwendung zu finden und dafür die
laborkapazitäten hochzufahren was
stellen wir heute fest heute sagt der
leiter ihres krisenstabes
wunder die kapazitäten im pcr bereich
sind erreicht was bedeutet das im
umkehrschluss wir werden am wochenende
die quarantänezeit und verkürzen
richtigerweise gerade für die gebäude im
gesundheitsbereich
richtigerweise auch für junge familien
junge väter und mütter die ihre kinder
frei testen lassen wollen aber sie haben
gar nicht die möglichkeit das ist
regierungsversagen der ampel koalition
unter olaf scholz und das ist ihnen
anzulasten sie haben nicht einen tag auf
den expertenrat gehört sie haben nicht
auf die wissenschaft gehört die gesagt
hat die omikron wand wird kommen wir
werden nächste woche über 100.000
neuinfektionen sehen wir werden nächste
woche die richtigerweise verkürzten
quarantäne zeiten gar nicht einhalten
können um diejenigen aus der jeweiligen
quarantäne raus zu testen und nun haben
ja einige koalitionäre das thema
digitalisierung angesprochen liebe fdp
wir sind dabei ihn wir freuen uns auf
ihrem vorschlag zum ins register dann
bringen sie den endlich ein für
digitalisierte aufnahmen haben damit wir
einen datenbestand haben da sind wir an
ihrer seite bringen sie das imwf
register voran das brauchen wir um
ideologisch auf die nächste pandemische
situation eingehen zu können und dann
hören wir dass junge menschen nicht zum
hausarzt gehen oder kein hausarzt haben
wenn sie sich liebe kollegin der fdp
vielleicht die hausarzt verteilung im
ländlichen raum anschauen dann liegt es
nicht daran dass junge menschen nicht
zum hausarzt gehen wollen sie können gar
nicht zum hausarzt gehen weil keine
hausärzte mehr vor ort sind und was
fordert ihre ampelkoalition
gemeindeschwestern und gemeinde und
gesundheitsnutzen das ist der absolute
wahnsinn da wird demnächst der 22
jährige fußballspieler an die hand
genommen dann ins im zentrum geführt
damit er sich die impfung abholt dass
wir von ihrer sogenannten liegende
koalition erwarten ich wollte ihnen noch
eine chance geben ihrer redezeit es gibt
nämlich eine zwischenfrage aus der
fraktion die linke das kann ich aber nur
so lange machen wie sie in ihrer rede
noch 20 sekunden
[Gelächter]
lieber kollege müller vielen vielen dank
ist ja ganz spannend dass die csu die
linke sich bei der testung sehr nah sind
wir haben im dezember
sie haben vom dezember gesprochen dass
es dem kollegen lauterbacher bewusst
sein müssen die labore aufzubauen wissen
sie wer noch bis november im
gesundheitsministerium waren mehrere
jahre die labore hätte aufbauen können
die es in anderen ländern übrigens auch
passiert ist die jetzt schon mit dem ptr
testung angefangen haben die frage
lautet also ganz einfach wer war denn im
november im gesundheitsministerium
vielen dank für die zwischenfrage oben
auch da einzugehen selbstverständlich
haben wir als unions fraktion auch in
der letzten bundesregierung dem
bundesgesundheitsminister gestellt der
bis november da war die omikron band
steht erst seit dezember vor der haustür
seit dezember übrigens vier tage vor
regierungswechsel erst vier tage vor
regierungswechsel klar gewesen wer
bundesgesundheitsminister wird und
deswegen ist die schuld in die schuhe
schieben bei anderen nicht angebracht
die verantwortung für die omikron band
liegt beim bundesgesundheitsminister
lauterbach und weil sie ihr so gastiert
haben wir würden da zusammen stehen uns
unterscheidet vor allem eins wir werden
dass ich nur fordern wir wollen da auch
vorangehen ich habe ja entnommen dass
sie auch beim thema pflege das thema
pflege bonus angesprochen haben da hört
man ja auch komische töne aus der ampel
koalition hier sind wir schon dabei zu
sagen wir wollen die medizinische
fachangestellte unterstützen wir wollen
die notfallsanitäter unterstützung das
ist der unterschied zwischen einer
konstruktiven opposition die heran schon
an anträgen arbeitet zu einer linken
koalition beziehungsweise opposition
entleeren
[Applaus]
sepp müller hat hier viel widerspruch
bei den anderen fraktionen hervor
gerufen aber auch er kritisiert noch
einmal dass der
bundesgesundheitsminister genau wie der
bundeskanzler zwar für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht seien aber kann nicht
willens seien offensichtlich auch nicht
in der lage einen eigenen gesetzentwurf
vorzulegen das haben ja gestern auch
schon immer wieder gehört als
argumentation aus der opposition saskia
weiter auf jetzt für die bündnisgrünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen
28 der auszubildenden in der pflege
berechnen ihre ausbildung wieder ab bei
kaum einem anderen bereich ist die
abbruchquote suchen gründe hierfür sind
so vielfältig wie ihm die menschen die
die ausbildung machen es lässt sich aber
leider ein muster erkennen
auszubildenden kehren der pflege den
rücken zu weil sie von den bedingungen
so erschöpft und enttäuscht sind dass
sie in der pflege einfach keine
zukunftsperspektive mehr sehen in einer
gesellschaftlich so stark vom
demografischen wandel betroffen ist es
stehen wir vor einem dilemma auf der
einen seite stehen die menschen die auf
pflegerische hilfe und unterstützung
angewiesen sind aber auf der anderen
seite halten immer mehr pflegende die
herrschenden arbeitsbedingungen einfach
nicht mehr aus die pflegen muss
attraktiver werden und dazu gehört eben
auch die ausbildung und genau das haben
wir uns als aufgabe
es geht aber nicht nur um junge menschen
die im beruf in der pflege finden räumt
es geht auch um die menschen seit jahren
und jahrzehnten bereits im krankenhaus
in praxen oder seniorenheim arbeiten sie
verdienen nicht nur unseren ablauf und
unseren respekt sondern auch eine
ernsthafte umsetzung ihrer anliegen
es ist daher lange überfällig was wir
als koalition auf den weg bringen wir
schaffen eine funktionierende und
verbindliche personalbemessung im
krankenhaus und schließen endlich die
bereits lücke zwischen der alten und
krankenpflege und sie ergänzen die
professionelle pflege durch neue
berufsbilder und
ja das muss natürlich auch gesagt werden
bonuszahlungen sind nett aber die
meisten wissen doch hier das pflegerin
ob in intensivpflege oder in der
altenpflege die medizinischen
fachangestellten kurzum die menschen die
unser gesundheitssystem am laufen halten
mehr brauchen sie verdienen ein
gesundheitssystem in dem sie ihren job
wieder so machen können wie sie gelernt
haben nahm menschen und für die menschen
und das den wir an
ich will noch eine zeit zahl in die
runde geben 88
ärztinnen sind derzeit auf der seite der
bundesärztekammer gelistet die in bayern
schwangerschafts abbrüche durchführen
kaum woanders ist die versorgungslage
von ungewollt schwangeren zum
mangelhaften bayern im mantel regionen
gibt es im umkreis von 200 kilometern
keine versorgung der schwangeren das
leben wirklich schützen will der gibt
informationen frei und das tun wir
endlich mit der streichung von 219 abend
es ist ein befreiungsschlag für
ungewollt schwangere die sich endlich
über eine gesundheitsleistung vernünftig
informieren können dieser schritt ist
weitreichend und ein erstes richtiges
und wichtiges signal für mehr
selbstbestimmung und da hören wir nicht
auf denn gemeinsam wollen wir auch
paragraf 218 auf den prüfstand stellen
und der arbeiten endlich eine regelung
die dem 21 jahrhundert endlich gerecht
wird
es sind aber nicht nur ungewollt
schwangere auch frauen die ihre
schwangerschaft weiterführen wollen
haben mit der wirklich mangelhaften
versorgung zu kämpfen mit einem
aktionsplan rund um die geburt wollen
die mütter und hebammen eine 1 1
betreuung garantieren und die
versorgungslücke während der
schwangerschaft endlich schließen
liebe kollegen die damen und herren im
jahr 20 22 ist es richtig zeit für eine
koalition die den pfleger in jedem land
eine perspektive gibt und die
bedürfnisse von frauen endlich ernst
nimmt dankeschön
der kollege professor andere ullmann r
bleibt das wort für die fdp
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
sehr verehrter herr minister lauterbach
wir brauchen endlich eine
perspektivenwechsel in der
gesundheitspolitik besonders politik
darf nicht mehr nur als kostenbelastung
verstanden werden und deshalb wollen wir
mehr gestalten statt verwalten
alle menschen in deutschland sollen gut
versorgt und gepflegt werden ob alt oder
jung mann oder frau den divers egal wo
sie wohnen im ländlichen regionen oder
in der stadt und egal wo sie herkommen
mehr denn je ist in der pandemie klar
geworden das ist nicht normal was
praktisches gesundheitssystem geht
sollen um menschen menschen sind ja auch
mal patientinnen und patienten menschen
arbeiten im gesundheitswesen wie
pflegerinnen und pfleger ärztlichen
ärzte physiotherapeuten und therapeuten
und viele mehr deshalb werden wir
diejenigen stärken die im
gesundheitssystem arbeiten und
patientinnen und patienten die modernste
effektivste gesetzliche versorgung
gewährleisten und dazu gehört auch die
aufwertung der zuwendung medizin wir
werden aber auch die
gesundheitsindustrie als wichtigen
arbeitgeber und wirtschaftsfaktor nach
vorne bringen die bedarfe der menschen
sind ja recht unterschiedlich und
deshalb ist die medizin der zukunft
individualisiert und
spezialisiert wir werden den weg der
maßgeschneiderten und fortschrittliche
medizin in der ampel konsequent ein
schlag
dazu möchte ich gerne zwei punkte
besonders hervorheben aus dem
koalitionsvertrag wir alle kennen die
probleme in den krankenhäuser und
notfallversorgung wir haben sie seit
jahren übrigens auch angemerkt diese
bundesregierung wird diese thematik auch
endlich angehen viele beklagen denn
nicht zurecht den wachsenden einfluss
der betriebswirtschaftlichen ziele auf
die medizinische versorgung in den
kliniken
fehlanreize in den abrechnungssystemen
bei der versorgung von patientinnen und
patienten unzureichende investitionen
der länder fehlende vorhaltekosten
stellenkürzungen sind häufig die folge
die gesundheitliche versorgung
verschlechtert sich auf dem rücken der
patientinnen und patienten und den
menschen dienen diesem gesundheitssystem
arbeiten dass hamster einmal damen und
herren läuft heiß burnout und zunehmende
unzufriedenheit auf allen ebenen werden
offensichtlich und diese herausforderung
stellen wir und werden sie beseitigen
wir wollen nämlich die arbeitsplätze
attraktiv machen damit die gesundheits
arbeiterinnen und arbeiter wieder gerne
zur arbeit gehen neben der dringend
notwendigen reform der fallpauschalen
will für die finanzierung der
krankenhäuser vorhalte pauschale
erarbeitet sie wird zu einer weiteren
wichtigen und neun säule der
finanzierung der krankenhäuser im ersten
schritt werden die kinderstation die
geburtshilfe und notfallversorgung
mengen unabhängig finanziert werden in
der ambulanten stationären versorgung
werden qualitätsvorgaben zunehmend eine
rolle spielen versorgungs endlich
vernetzter gedacht werden ambulante und
stationäre versorgung wird zusammen
weiterentwickelt im sinne einer
sektorenübergreifenden
versorgungsplanung um unnötige
stationäre krankenhausaufenthalte der
betroffenen zu ersparen
im zweiten punkt nicht als unwichtig war
haben wir auch im letzten
legislaturperiode gekämpft während wir
uns verantwortungsvoll für eine neue
moderne drogenpolitik einsetzen zum
beispiel die kontrollierte abgabe von
cannabis an erwachsene eine
legalisierung mit ihm sind schwarz war
endlich ein damit die qualität von
illegalen groben kann auch so überwacht
werden es wird viel weniger vom
unterricht substanz und vergiftungen
geben der jugendschutz besser zu
gewährleisten und das meine damen und
herren ist moderne und gute
drogenpolitik
wir als fortschritts regierung haben uns
gesundheitspolitisch ambitionierte ziele
für die kommenden vier jahre im gesetz
viele punkte konnte man jetzt in dieser
kürze nicht aufhören aber ein punkt
dürfen wir nicht vergessen wir haben das
heute sehr viel über die pandemie
gesprochen die auch global stattfindet
und ich weiß auch dass kollege karl
lauterbach hier mit seinem bmw hatte
dagegen kämpft wir dürfen nicht
vergessen dass diese pandemie global
wütet und als fortschritt koalitionäre
denken lokal handeln lokal
entschuldigung denken wir global handeln
lokal und europäische
die die pandemie krise
jetzt schon sehen ja wie
diese pandemie krise bietet uns die
chance für veränderung und fortschritt
las und wilders zusammen angehen die
freue mich auf die nächsten jahre in der
zusammenarbeit in der ampel für eine
moderne gesundheitswesen dankeschön
professor andre willmann ist ja selber
arzt und ist er jene hier im parlament
der den gruppen unserer ausformuliert
für eine impfpflicht für menschen über
50 diese gibt es zum beispiel in
australien oder auch neu einzuführen in
italien der nächste redner in dieser
debatte kommt von der cdu/csu erwin
rüddel
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren zunächst zum
thema impfpflicht die ampel muss hier
liefern die koalition muss sagen was sie
will und das nicht nur in sachen im
pflicht sondern auch in frage in der
frage im register weil das eine hängt
sehr sehr eng mit dem anderen zusammen
das ist nicht die aufgabe der opposition
das ist ihr auftrag sie haben die
mehrheit sie haben die den
regierungsauftrag und sie haben die
verantwortung also hören sie auf bei der
impfpflicht rumzueiern und sagen sie den
menschen in deutschland was sie vorhaben
und ob sie hinter ihrem kanzler und
ihrem gesundheitsminister stehen hören
sie auf sich hinter gewissensfragen zu
verschanzen um ihre uneinigkeit
herauszustellen als wir über die masern
im pflicht gesprochen haben und als wir
über die impfpflicht für die pflege
diskutiert haben war das thema
gewissensentscheidung nicht auf der
tagesordnung mit einem wort meine
fraktion erwartet von ihnen von der
ampel einen gesetzesvorschlag mit
substanz und wir werden den dann
entsprechend bewerten und ihnen sagen
was wir davon halten meine damen und
herren
von nikon ist offenbar dabei die
spielregeln zu verändern die vero sagt
voraus dass sich in den nächsten acht
wochen in europa mehr als 50 der
bevölkerung mit omikron infizieren
könnten auch mit schärferen maßnahmen
werden wir das kaum verhindern
umso dringlicher ist es die
digitalisierung unseres
gesundheitswesens voranzubringen
beispielsweise haben bund und länder vor
mehr als einem jahr mit den pakt für den
öbb 4 milliarden euro speziell zur
digitalisierung der gesundheitsämter zur
verfügung gestellt und ich höre gern
dass sie den von uns eingeschlagenen weg
zur besseren digitalisierung des
gesundheitssystems aktiv weiter
beschreiten wollen wir benötigen zur
bekämpfung von kogit 19 endlich valide
daten das bedeutet möglicherweise auch
eine abwägung mit dem datenschutz zur
bekämpfung der pandemie muss immer auch
wieder an grundrechten herangegangen
werden dabei darf der datenschutz keine
sonderstellung als super koste
grundrecht einnehmen aber wir reden
heute nicht nur über corona wir haben
natürlich verständnis dafür dass in der
pandemie der gesundheitsminister hier
seine schwerpunkte in der pandemie
bekämpfung legen muss trotzdem stellen
sich mit blick auf allerhand
ankündigungen im koalitionsvertrag
fragen die bald beantwortet werden
müssen das stichwort digitalisierung
haben wir bereits gehört der zum
jahreswechsel
geplante start des rezeptes wurde leider
verschoben und bestehen wie geht es
weiter mit den künftigen krankenkassen
und pflegebeiträge
was wird aus der garantie die
sozialbeiträge nicht über 40 prozent
steigen zu lassen eine frage die
angesichts der inflation und der
höchsten kaufkraft verluste seit
jahrzehnten für millionen von menschen
von besonderer bedeutung sind wie stellt
sich der minister zur künftigen planung
und finanzierung der krankenhäuser wie
zu der notfallversorgung was planen sie
konkret zur überwindung von
sektorengrenzen und wird die ampel das
versprechen einhalten künftig höhere gkv
beiträge aus steuermitteln für die
bezieher von arbeitslosengeld 2 beziehen
zu leisten dass meine damen und herren
sind nur einige der fragen die in den
nächsten wochen und monaten vom neuen
gesundheitsminister
beantwortet werden müssen vielen dank er
würde war das so der vergangenen
legislaturperiode vorsitzender im
auswärtigen ausschuss der auswärtige
ausschuss ist ja einer von drei
ausschüssen bei dem der vorsitz der afg
zusteht und wo die drei afg kandidaten
aber bislang nicht gewählt wurden durch
die anderen ausschussmitglieder
und die nächste rednerin hier jetzt im
parlament ist die gesundheitspolitische
sprecherin der spd-bundestagsfraktion
heike behrens
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
im stresstest der pandemie zeigen sich
deutlich die stärken und schwächen
unseres gesundheitssystems hoher
medizinischer standard
außerordentliche leistungsfähigkeit
unserer krankenhäuser und unserer
ambulanten versorgungsstrukturen aber
auf der anderen seite ausgeprägter
personalmangel in allen pflegebereichen
schlecht ausgestattete und überforderter
öffentlicher gesundheitsdienst und noch
immer nicht überwunden
abstimmungsprobleme zwischen bund und
den bundesländern große
herausforderungen denen sich die neue
koalition mit großem
verantwortungsbewusstsein
stellt mit dem mut und der lust zu
fortschritt und aufbruch
bürgerfreundlicher transparenter
unbürokratischer soll der sozialstaat
werden auch in der gesundheits- und
pflegepolitik wir werden die
verkrusteten strukturen in der pflege
aufbrechen und die sektorenübergreifende
versorgung voranbringen wir werden
entscheidungsprozesse beschleunigen denn
der warum eigentlich geht es nicht voran
mit den personalschlüssel in der pflege
und mit der pr 2.0 im krankenhaus das
werden wir vorantreiben
wir werden die digitalisierung und
entbürokratisierung antreiben damit
pflege wirklich pflegen kann damit
ärztinnen mit ihren patienten zeit zum
sprechen haben überbelastung
unterbesetzung schwierige
arbeitsbedingungen das muss ein ende
haben weil es die pflege selbst krank
macht
gute pflege
braucht gute bezahlung und das muss
selbstverständlich werden und darum
braucht es endlich einen ordentlichen
pflege tarifvertrag
ja das alles kostet viel geld aber das
muss es uns wert sein denn nur so kann
es gelingen mehr menschen für diese so
wichtigen berufe zu gewinnen nur so
schützen und fördern wir das öffentliche
gut pflege denn das muss allen
inzwischen klar sein es gibt tatsächlich
noch etwas schlimmeres als teure pflege
nämlich keine pflege und deshalb müssen
wir in unserer alternden gesellschaft
dafür sorgen dass diese größte
herausforderung genug menschen für diese
wichtigen berufe zu gewinnen
dass wir die wirklich mit langem atem
anpacken und es ist auch eine frage des
respekts wie unser kanzler olaf scholz
sehr nachdrücklich immer wieder betont
respekt vor dem leben des einst jedes
einzelnen menschen aber eben auch
respekt besonders vor dem was in der
pflege geleistet wird
noch etwas anderes hat uns die pandemie
wie unter einem brennglas gezeigt
nämlich dass es nicht ausreicht einfach
nur die stärken unseres
gesundheitssystems auszubauen und unsere
schwächen zu beheben
vielmehr ist es dringend nötig bei
dieser debatte über den eigenen
tellerrand
hinauszuschauen
denn wer die pandemie unter kontrolle
bringen will muss den blick auf das
globale ganze richten
mit mindestens genauso viel energie die
für unsere heimische impfkampagne müssen
wir dazu beitragen dass weltweit alle
menschen geimpft werden können wir
brauchen noch mehr einsatz bei kovacs
dem vorteil impfstoff verteil
mechanismus der
weltgesundheitsorganisation und ein
überzeugenderes engagement der
impfstoffhersteller beim aufbau von
produktionskapazitäten im globalen süden
wenn unternehmen wie pfizer oder
moderne auch durch die guten preise die
von den einkommen starken nationen
gezahlt werden derzeit pro sekunde
1000 dollar verdienen dann haben sie die
verdammte pflicht dafür zu sorgen dass
endlich auch die menschen in den ärmsten
ländern dieser welt geimpft werden
können
nur so kommen wir aus dem strudel
heraushole rings immer neue mutationen
bescheren kann möchten sie denn eine
zwischenfrage der politik foto zu lassen
ganz genau lieber kollege sorge liebe
kolleginnen alge während ich
finde sie haben da an wichtigen und
richtigen punkt angesprochen und ich
freue mich auch dass die
regierungsfraktionen diese sachlage
erkannt haben aber warum verschließen
sie sich denn nach wie vor der forderung
wichtiger großer schwellen und
entwicklungsländer die patente für
medizinprodukte arzneimittel &
medikamente
und impfstoffe
aufzuheben damit auch fabriken
beispielsweise in südafrika indien oder
in anderen ländern des globalen südens
in die lage versetzt werden ohne
lizenzzahlungen an die ohnehin sehr gut
verdienenden pharmaunternehmen in den
reichen ländern selber diese notwendigen
produkte zur bewältigung der
pandemie zu produzieren und damit eben
auch ein grundstock zu legen gegen die
entstehung immer neuer immer neuer virus
varianten die dann ja auch zu uns kommen
viele dankbar für diese nachfrage sie
kennen ja meine persönliche haltung dazu
und ich kann ihnen auch klar sagen diese
regierung verschließt sich dieser
diskussion nicht sondern darüber wird
sehr ernsthaft nachgedacht wie man und
ob es der richtige weg ist tatsächlich
mit der vorübergehenden aussetzung von
patenten eben den zugang zu den
impfstoffen tatsächlich zu beschleunigen
denn natürlich braucht der
produktionsaufbau auch in dann in den
ländern des globalen südens sehr viel
zeit wir brauchen aber heute den zugang
zu den impfstoffen und deshalb mein
klarer appell an die impfstoffhersteller
sie haben es in der hand heute dafür zu
sorgen dass impfstoffe eben nicht nur
dorthin schnell hin gelangen wo hohe
preise gezahlt werden sondern die
impfstoffe müssen auch dorthin wo hohe
preise nicht gezahlt werden können und
die menschen selbst diese impfstoffe so
nicht erhalten vielen dank
[Applaus]
sehr gerne
vielen dank frau kollegin deren die
zwischenfrage zu lassen sie hatten ja in
ihren letzten ausführungen wieder das
übliche argument ist dass sozialen eines
ausgeführt so von wegen dass die bösen
unternehmen doch mehr zahlen sollten
sich gar nicht an einen bestimmten
sozialen dingen beteiligen würden und
ich würde sie gern fragen wir haben ja
in deutschland glücklicherweise mit
beyond unternehmen was sehr innovativ
auch bei der frage der impfstoffe ist
ist ihnen bekannt dass biontech im
letzten jahr über eine milliarde euro an
steuern an die stadt einst zahlt oder
zahlen wird das sogar ihr kollege der
oberbürgermeister ebling seines zeichens
spd-oberbürgermeister
das ausdrücklich mit freude zur kenntnis
genommen hat die passt das in ihrer
ausführung das unternehmen sich an
solchen dingen nicht beteiligen das
würde mich mal interessieren vielen dank
vielen dank herr sorge für die
nachfrager zunächst mal habe ich
überhaupt nicht über sozialneid
gesprochen das will ich erst mal klar
stellen
zum zweiten sollte es selbstverständlich
sein dass unternehmen die in unserem
land gewinne erwirtschaften in unserem
land dort wo sie ihre standorte haben
ordentlich steuern zahlen
und es ist gut für die stadt mainz ist
es gut für das land rheinland pfalz das
dort diese firma ansässig ist aber es
ist mindestens genauso gut dass dieses
land deutschland mit seinen forschungs
und förderprogrammen ganz wesentlich
dazu beigetragen hat dass diejenigen die
zum beispiel an krebsmedikamenten
geforscht haben jetzt die möglichkeit
hatten diese jahrzehntelange forschung
umzusetzen um ganz schnell einen
impfstoff zu produzieren
das ist hoch anerkennenswert aber ist
auch zustande gekommen weil diese
unternehmen weil diese forscherinnen und
forscher öffentlich gefördert wurden und
deshalb haben diese unternehmen sind auf
die verantwortung
diese dies was dabei herausgekommen ist
und was nun zu änderungen renditen führt
das auch wieder einer gemeinwohl
verantwortung zuzuführen und da sage ich
da haben wir international eine große
verantwortung da haben auch die
unternehmen eine riesengroße
verantworten
ja ich bin der festen überzeugung dass
investitionen in gesundheit weltweit
sich auszahlen werden vielfach auszahlen
werden denn wo menschen öffentlich
abgesichert oder sozialversichert sind
werden sie eben nicht von den
verhandlungs kosten überfordert und den
armut gedrängt und wo alle
bevölkerungsgruppen direkten zugang zur
notwendigen gesundheitsversorgung haben
da können sie ein leben in würde führen
das ist die grundlage für
gesellschaftliche und wirtschaftliche
entwicklung das ist eine
grundvoraussetzung dafür dass staaten in
frieden miteinander leben und handeln
können und dafür brauchen wir auch eine
starte weltgesundheitsorganisation als
leitende koordinierende instanz beim
krisenmanagement zur prävention und für
den aufbau einer universellen
gesundheitsversorgung für alle und dafür
sollte sich deutschland auch in zukunft
stark machen
komme es zum schluss da wir wissen
worauf es ankommt in der nationalen und
globalen gesundheitspolitik und ich
freue mich mit ihnen gemeinsam daran
arbeiten zu können vielen dank
heute gehen zwar dass für die
spd-bundestagsfraktion der nächste
redner stefan pischinger
gesundheitspolitiker der csu sorgte für
reichlich verwirrung am anfang der woche
hatte er doch gesagt die unionsfraktion
werde einen eigenen antrag ausarbeiten
zur impfpflicht und er musste dann
zurückgepfiffen werden oder anders
interpretiert werden auf jeden fall hat
die fraktionsführung am dienstag dann
klar gestellt so wird es nicht sein
am 12 januar haben die gesundheitsämter
dem robert-koch-institut
80.000 430 neue krone ansteckung in
deutschland gemeldet das sind so viele
wie nie zuvor an einem tag in dieser
partie kanzler olaf scholz hat schon im
november
2021 mitgeteilt dass der deutsche
bundestag bis ende februar
2022 ein gesetz zur allgemeinen im
pflicht beschließen soll und was hat die
bundesregierung bisher an
gesetzesentwürfen oder wenigstens an
formulierungshilfen zur einführung der
impfpflicht geliefert die der bundestag
ordentlich beraten könnte was hat die
bundesregierung bisher getan die
hochinfektiöse omikron variante
rechtzeitig durch eine impfpflicht
einzudämmen ich sage es ihnen nicht
einfach gar nichts
meine damen und herren hier zeigt sich
leider sehr deutlich dass links gelb bei
der pandemie bekämpfung bei der sehr
wichtigen frage um die impfpflicht noch
immer kein konzept hat aus angst diesen
unstrittig richtigen thema drückt sich
die ampel weg und hofft auf
interfraktionelle gruppenanträge ich
muss es leider so sagen herr scholz hat
in dieser frage nicht genug
führungsstärke und die ampel kein
kompass in der pandemie bekämpfen
die die wahrheit ist das wird langsam
geben klar weil die ampel keine eigene
mehrheit für ein gesetz zu einer wie
auch immer ausgestalteten impfpflicht
hat macht sie diese ganz klar politische
frage über eine helmpflicht plötzlich zu
einer ethischen gewissensentscheidung
und hofft dass diese entscheidung
irgendwie mit tatkräftiger hilfe der
opposition gefällt ich frag
entschuldigung herr kollege es gibt den
wunsch nach einer zwischenfrage aus der
af die fraktion
möchte lassen dass ich dann bitte schön
vielen dank herr kollege für das
zulassen dieser zwischen frage nach dem
was sie eben gesagt haben entsteht für
mich der eindruck dass sie bzw
die kollegen ihrer cdu fraktion ohne
wenn und aber für eine impfpflicht
eintreten haben wir dass ihr alle
richtig verstanden
die brille gesehen doch konnten sie ihre
maske richtig auch damit müssen dem
antrag man ja auch meist noch danke
schön herr kollege vielen dank für ihre
zwischen frage die es zulässt dass wir
mal klar machen wo unsere position ist
wir sind der meinung dass die regierung
hier in diesem haus einen ordentlichen
und rechtssicheren vorschlag vorlegen
muss und dann werden wir das als union
bewerten und entsprechende vorschläge
machen ich glaube das ist der richtige
rahmen und ich glaube im inhalt des
gesetzes werden wir auch unsere
zustimmung daran festmachen und deswegen
sagen wir ohne wenn und aber ist der
falsche ausdruck wir wollen einen guten
gesetzlichen rahmen und den werden wir
bewerten wenn hier in diesem haus ein
gesetzesvorschlag vorliegt
ich frage gibt es einen signifikanten
grund warum die einführung einer
impfpflicht für das pflegepersonal ende
letzten jahres oder die maßen
impfpflicht in der letzten
legislaturperiode keine
gewissensentscheidung waren und die
allgemeine impfpflicht jetzt eine sein
soll die gestrige regierungsbefragung
von olaf scholz hat es klar gezeigt der
bundeskanzler hat darauf keine
befriedigende antwort es gibt einfach
keinen wirklichen grund dafür sehr
geehrter herr bundeskanzler scholz sehr
geehrt der gesundheitsminister
lauterbach kommen sie jetzt rasch dieser
ihnen aufgetragen aufgabe nach
übernehmen sie als regierung
verantwortung und legen sie endlich
einen rechtssicheren und vernünftigen
gesetzentwurf vor über den das parlament
dann ordentlich beraten und entscheiden
kann wir als union werden sie dann gerne
konstruktiv an dieser debatte beteiligen
das ist das verantwortungsbewusstsein
dass ich von einer bundesregierung
eigentlich erwarten würde denn
wenn sie wollen herr lauterbach können
wir sie als neue service opposition auch
gerne beraten wir laden sie ein kommen
sie ausnahmsweise mal zu uns in den
gesundheitsausschuss dann müssen sie
auch zum diskutieren nicht mehr so weit
nach hamburg zu markus lanz fahren für
ein entferntes dar die sie nehmen wir
uns immer gerne zeit
inzwischen fallen heraus ja auch immer
heute auch gerne noch eine stelle das
ist dann die letzte die ich in dieser
rede doch lasse
für die übrigen nummer schon
ja ja danke dass sie die frage zu lassen
meine frage gerade das über die
impfpflicht gesprochen haben gibt es in
ihrer fraktion eigentlich eine
positionierung bezüglich impfpflicht
haben sie eine position oder haben sie
keine und das sind sie noch am überlegen
und wenn sie vorschläge unterbreiten
haben sie schon dem ministerium an
nachgefragt ob sie die
formulierungshilfe haben wollen also
herr kollege vielen dank für die
nachfrage die natürlich sind wir in der
entscheidungsfindung phase aber dafür
brauchen wir wichtige informationen aus
dem ministerium
die haben wir vor weihnachten schon
gestellt fachfragen die wichtig sind so
richtig schwierige entscheidungsfindung
leider mit keine antwort erhalten
deswegen müssen wir als opposition das
parlamentarische fragerecht in anspruch
nehmen um unsere antworten zu erzwingen
wenn der minister schon von sich heraus
unseren antworten nachgekommen wäre dann
hätten wir auch schon in teams vorschlag
vorliegen können aber leider ist es
nicht erfolgt und deswegen brauchen wir
und hoffen auf die guten antworten
hoffen fachlicher seite vom ministerium
dann können wir auch gut entscheiden sie
haben kann
über was wir auch erst auftreten müssen
herr minister auf eine parlamentarische
anfrage hin hatten ihre parlamentarische
staatssekretärin sabine mit dittmar
mitgeteilt dass die bundesregierung die
medizinischen fachangestellten in den
niedergelassenen praxen im gegensatz zu
den pflegekräften in den krankenhäusern
und pflegeheimen keinen staatlichen
corona sonderbonus zahlen will das ist
eine himmelschreiende ungerechtigkeit
die in dieser pandemie wirklich
seinesgleichen zu machen die
bundesregierung denkt also dass die
arzthelferin und arzthelfer mit ihren
kleinen gehältern im gegensatz zum
personalen im pflegeheim nicht leisten
um staatlich auch angemessen honoriert
zu werden das ist unanständig und auch
inhaltlich falsch ohne den enormen
arbeitseinsatz der arzthelferin und a 24
in den ambulanten versorgung hätten viel
mehr patienten in den krankenhäusern
behandelt werden müssen das hätte unser
gesundheitssystem wahrscheinlich
wirklich kollabieren lassen und ohne die
medizinischen fachangestellten wäre die
organisation und durchführung von
millionen kronen impfungen in den praxen
sicher so nicht möglich gibt kollege
gehen dann also geben sie sich einen
ruck der lauterbach zeigten sie mehr
anerkennen für diese um bis zur
erschöpfung geben täglichen leistung
unsere medizinischen fachangestellten in
den praxen das wäre dann wirklich eine
frage der wenn ich dann sage meine ich
dass die jede zeit zu ende ist aber ich
ja zumal der minister bereits im
plenarsaal verlassen hat er ist hier
eben an uns vorbei gekommen hat gewählt
seine stimme abgegeben
die wahl läuft ja immer noch da geht es
ja um die wahlvorschläge wahl der
vertreter der bundesrepublik deutschland
in die parlamentarische versammlung des
europarates dieser abstimmung wird noch
eine gute halbe stimme gelaufen und
derweil geht es munter weiter im
plenarsaal armin grau von den
bündnisgrünen ist jetzt der letzte
redner zudem debatte punkt gesundheit
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen unser
gesundheitswesen hat die extremen
anforderungen in der korona pandemie gut
gemeistert die beschäftigten in
krankenhäusern und praxen und anderen
einrichtungen haben gewaltiges geleistet
dafür gebührt ihnen unser großer dank
aber unsere gesundheitswesen hat auch
seine verletzlichkeit gezeigt und es ist
wichtig jetzt zügig reformen anzupacken
um eine bedarfsgerechte versorgung
gesundheitsversorgung zu sichern rund 60
prozent der deutschen krankenhäuser
rechnung 20 21 mit verlusten hier werden
wir es als ampel verhindern dass corona
zu einem krankenhaus sterben führt die
pandemie hat deutlich gemacht wie
wichtig die vorhaltung von
versorgungskapazitäten ist die aktuelle
finanzierung der betriebskosten der
krankenhäuser bruder fall porsche das
bedeutet dass die ohnehin vorhanden und
kosten die vorhaltekosten über einzelne
patientin finanziert werden daraus
resultieren wirtschaftlichen
fehlanreizen zu fallzahl ausweitung und
zur erbringung besonders lukrative
leistungen das ist längst nicht immer
bedarfsgerecht patientinnen werden zum
wirtschaftsfaktor und ärzten stehen oft
im zermürbenden zielkonflikt zwischen
den ökonomischen interessen ihres
krankenhauses und interessen ihre
patientin habe 19 jahre lang eine klinik
geleitet und kenne diese konflikte mir
liegt am herzen dass jetzt positive
veränderungen geschafft werden etwas was
die vorgehen der regierung in keiner
weise getan hat
ein wichtiger schritt ist einiges andere
finanzierung von vorhaltekosten ein
punkt der uns grünen im
koalitionsvertrag sehr wichtig war
parallel dazu bringen wir eine struktur
reform auf den weg die
krankenhausplanung muss gestärkt und
dabei erreichbarkeit und regionale
krankheitshäufigkeit
berücksichtigt werden mit einem pulk
länderpark müssen die stark
unterfinanzierten
krankenhausinvestitionen verbessert
werden im gesundheitswesen ist
zusammenarbeit trumpf deswegen wollen
wir eine gemeinsame ambulante und
stationäre versorgungsplanung bislang
unnötig stationär erbrachte leistungen
erfolgen zukünftig ambulant in
gesundheitsregion und fördern wir über
berufsgruppen und sektoren hinweg die
zusammenarbeit armut macht krank daher
machen wir ein besonders benachteiligten
regionen neue niedrigschwellige angebote
ich freue mich dass wir diese punkte im
koalitionsvertrag
unterbringen konnten
gesundheitsversorgung ist
daseinsvorsorge
der leitfaden unserer politik ist eine
klare orientierung am nutzen für die
menschen im land auch wirtschaftlich
gesehen ist das langfristig die klügste
strategien zu entwickeln wir in und nach
der pandemie und sie bereits selbst
stark ist gesundheitswesen weiter ich
freue mich auf die zusammenarbeit hier
in diesem haus vielen dank
wegen des kriegs das war top in der zeit
und sehr erstaunlich für eine erste rede
insofern damit sind wir am ende dieses
themenbereiches